literally everyone listened to this this
is the number one mistake that i see
entrepreneurs make that i made
growing up so please do not do this
because it is incredibly painful and it
takes so long to get out of so please do
not do this
so i was talking to entrepreneur and i
said
you have three businesses and you've got
three different product lines in each of
those businesses and i'll bet you right
now that eighty percent of your revenue
comes from just twenty percent of that
stuff prettis principle nothing nothing
crazy here and he looked at all of his
numbers he was like yeah i guess this is
really the main thing and i was like why
did you do all these other things he
said well seemed like a good idea at the
time and it just felt like there was
just extra money sitting there on the
table that we should just grab here's
what's crazy
the extra money that's sitting there on
the table
is the money that distracts you from the
main game i like to use this principle
called the women in the red dress so if
you've seen the matrix right which is my
favorite movie of all time morpheus is
explaining to neo that uh anybody in the
matrix could be an agent right so
there's a woman in the red dress who
walks by and then all of a sudden he
turns back around and it's an agent
right and i like to use that analogy
because the woman in the red dress is
the distractions that we use the easy
money that's sitting there on the
sideline
so i had a conversation with an
entrepreneur um
in the digital marketing space doing
about five four five million a year
and
he said i think i want to do general
business coaching because i've got all
these people who are asking me for
general business coaching and i was like
why on earth would you do that he's like
well i mean they're just they're asking
i'm just turning money down and i was
like
that's the point that is the point of a
strategy a strategy is learning when to
say no
and so i said hold on for a second
before you do this right you have your
business right now
and because it's hard for you to grow it
you're going to choose to distract
yourself from something that's going to
give you an easy win which gives you
that nice dopamine hit literally
everyone listen to this this is the
number one mistake that i see
entrepreneurs make that i made
growing up so please do not do this
because it is incredibly painful and it
takes so long to get out of so please do
not do this all right
what they do is that the thing they have
becomes hard because they reach a
limitation either on their beliefs their
skills or their character traits and so
as a result of that limitation on the
ladder that they've built for themselves
with beliefs on one side character each
other to the other and skills just the
middle runs that they have to grab
because you have to have all three in
order to grab the next wrong right they
have those those those aspects and they
hit a level and what they do is they see
another ladder next to them that has
some rungs already built because they
have those things and they just jump
onto that ladder but then they climb and
then they reach another pinnacle that's
still not above their first ladders
limit right of skills character traits
and beliefs and so
what happens is they make this jump and
so i was going back to this entrepreneur
and i was like hey man
so
could you imagine a world how easy would
it be
for you
if you just eliminated everything in
your business and all you do is grow
this one thing i said how easy would
that be and he was like dude that would
be easy as hell it's like you know 80 of
my time is dealing with all these other
things and the operational drag and
complexity around you know these other
teams and blah blah blah i was like
right
so why don't you do that
and so when i come into most businesses
most of the times i get the entrepreneur
to do less i get the business to do
fewer things because simple you can
write this down write this down
simple scales
fancy fails you can use that you can
take it to the bank uncormozy all right
mosey nation that's one of our one of
our one of our tenants all right simple
scales fancy fails and if you got a
fancy business i'll tell you the richest
guys in the world have simple ass
businesses and they have the character
traits to see that woman in the red
dress walk by and say not today nancy
not today i'm good you're not going to
you're not going to seduce me today into
into some quick money that's going to
take me away from the long term goal
that's what strategy is it's learning to
say no it's learning to say no because
you know that your marriage in the long
term is going to get you higher returns
than the short term quick fix right and
that's a character trait that you have
to develop and here's what's crazy the
higher up in business you go the higher
up that ladder that you climb
the sexier the woman in the red dress
looks like the sexier the seduction
appears the sexier the temptation
appears because right now if someone
were to come to me and say
let's say uh or let's just say that
you're making a million dollars a year
all right in your business let's say
you're netting 250 whatever all right
just as a hypothetical example if
someone came to you right now and said
dude i can help you make an extra
thousand dollars a month you'd be like
i'm good no thanks right but if someone
came to you and said hey man i can help
you make an extra fifty thousand dollars
a month you might be tempted by that
right or maybe an extra an extra hundred
thousand you might be tempted by that
right
but
the reality is that it's just a woman in
the red dress it's agent smith is hiding
pretending to be this this thing that's
going to give you the short-term win
when in reality all it's going to do is
distract you from the long-term success
that you're trying to have because if
you just match the market and you just
do the one thing over and over again if
you just repeat successful actions if
you have aggressive patients if you do
the boring work and you let it compound
and you let compounding happen for you
and with you instead of against you and
you use time as an asset instead of a
liability instead of being in a rush all
the time you actually use patience as a
as a lever on your success use time as
an asset that works for you instead of
against you and if you if you can do
those things
you'll be unreasonably successful but
it's because you took decisions you made
decisions you had character traits that
were unreasonable and un
uncommon
right uncommon success is not because
it's complex it's because it's hard
and it's hard not because it's
complicated it's hard because it's so
simple no one does it we let our
humanity in our irrationality and our
need for immediate short-term wins get
in the way of what our long-term
strategy is and i'll say this again
strategy is knowing what you say no to
not what you say yes to if you think
about who you serve who your avatar is
what you help them do you get a lot more
strength in knowing what you don't do
you have to turn money down you know
much money i turn down every day like i
literally get a dm i probably get two
dms a day saying hey man um i'll pay you
10 grand for an hour of time i'm just
like dude i just don't
it's just not i can't like i can't say
yes that's just distracting to me to to
do what i'm trying to do and the thing
is is that that woman in the red dress
the higher up you become the more sexy
she becomes and one of the biggest i
mean the mistakes i've made i made many
of these mistakes i think i started my
second business too early i started
prestige labs or supplement company too
early and i think i suffered for that it
took i think it basically flatlined our
growth for two years because of that and
it took me to care to develop all these
other character traits that i had to do
instead to learn how to actually i went
from running one business to running two
businesses
and i'll just give you this quick tidbit
if you're listening to this you might be
thinking well alex how do you have these
women in the red dress because you now
have you know six seven whatever we have
a lot in our portfolio now how do you
reconcile that well now for me the
portfolio is the one thing my portfolio
is the one thing
and that is the that's kind of the
overarching thing for me now is that
i
did this out of sequence and so don't
make please don't make the mistake you
can do whatever you want but like for me
this is a mistake i made is that if
you're running a business
and here's how you define running a
business if the business
does not grow without you spending less
than five hours a week on it
for six straight months
and you never have to jump back in
that is when you are you have
transitioned from ceo to owner
all right and right now fyi if it means
if you have if you don't have to do
anything you're not part of the
fulfillment right
but you're still ceo
if you're still ceo
every business needs a ceo right every
business needs somebody who's driving
the business if you're just not involved
in the quote day-to-day you still 100
have a job it's just not time oriented
but you still 100 have a job but what
you need is to make sure that you get
your attention back and the way to get
your attention back is to let someone
else have the intention of running the
business which is
making sure that you can then move up
and then you can make your net worth
your portfolio your assets the one thing
right and so anywho all of us have a
woman in the red dress right that 5
million entrepreneur all of us have that
quick win that we want to have because
we have some level of demand that's
there
but you have to say no
at least that's my my two cents that's
been my experience you have to say no
until you get to the point where even
when you start that new thing right
starting a new thing you're not starting
a new thing you're assembling the team
that's going to pursue this opportunity
on your behalf
think about like to think about the
language behind that you're not going to
go start another business you're going
to go assemble a team that's going to
pursue that opportunity because you
think it's worth pursuing
think about that way right or you
acquire a business or a percentage of a
business and then you help assist that
team grow and pursue that opportunity
that is how owners speak versus ceos
right that is how you go from
self-employed to owner and most of us
um especially you know younger
entrepreneurs and i'm not saying
i say younger not in terms of age i just
say in terms of experience they're still
self-employed you're ceo but you're
still self-employed right and i think
that if you can make that and you can
swallow your pride about saying like oh
i have this business
and you just realized that um then
you'll you'll you'll be much more
successful so let's go back to the very
beginning to wrap this puppy up if you
have lots of little things in your
business and you have one big thing
that's really the majority of your your
income if you cut out all of these other
things and make your business so simple
it would be unreasonable or unreasonable
for you not to be successful if you do
that then you probably will be
successful because it would be
unreasonable for you not to but the
thing is it's hard
not because it's complicated but because
it forces us to go against our human
nature and i think if you can think
about things like that like charlie
munger and warren buffett like they
don't spend that much time working
right they spend their time making good
decisions which doesn't take that much
time it just takes a lot of intelligent
or sorry a lot of good discipline and
character traits right and so if you
look at what they do
if i think about that like just because
something is simple doesn't mean it's
not the right call
simple scales fancy fails and i'll leave
you with that i can tell you right now
we make more money like we make a lot of
money right now and
we really don't do a ton and it's
because i had to change my beliefs about
like we we we do these things because we
have these interpersonal needs we have
these character traits we have these
deficiencies that we we choose to fill
with our business and our activities
because we don't want to be alone with
our thoughts but if you can let your
business just continue to run and not go
in and mess things up because you've
gotten to that point you've put you know
a ceo in place you will be best served
and so anyways stop being so fancy
simple scales fancy fails and if you're
not at that point then be okay with not
being at that point don't be too good to
run your own business don't feel like oh
i have to do what alex is doing because
everything has to be done in sequence
until you until you know
how to get to owner you shouldn't try
and do that yet so you'll be successful
so anyways um i hope you enjoyed this uh
confront the hard work and the hard work
a lot of times is simple work it's
simple decisions that we have to make
don't take the quick wins think long
aggressive patience macro perspective
and i think that
i think that will all ultimately be the
better for it at least these journals
these little vlogs are for me to to
write down the principles that that have
made uh given us disproportionate
returns and i hope to share them with
you mozi nation keeping awesome catch
you next video bye